une décision pour l'histoire c'est en
ces termes que la Maison Blanche exhorte
le congrès à voter une nouvelle aide
financière pour
l'Ukraine si le Congrès n'agit pas d'ici
la fin de l'année nous serons à cours de
ressources pour livrer plus d'armes et
d'équipement à
l'Ukraine voter contre un financement
supplémentaire nuira à l'Ukraine et
aidera la Russie cela nuira à la
démocratie et aidera les dictateurs en
jeu une enveloppe exceptionnelle de plus
de 100 milliards de dollars réclamée
depuis octobre par le président
démocrate Joe Biden mais le capital
bloque en cause des dissensions entre
partis politiques le Congrès à majorité
républicaine n'a toujours pas voté de
budget annuel indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de l'État fédéral un peu
plus tôt avant cette conférence de
presse la pression est venue de la
directrice du budget de la Maison
Blanche chaland day Jong s'est adressé
directement au patron de la Chambre des
représentants par courrier lequel n'a
pas tardé à répondre sèchement sur x
l'administration Biden est incapable de
répondre aux inquiétudes légitimes des
conservateurs de mon groupe
parlementaire sur l'absence de stratégie
claire pour l'Ukraine sur une issue au
conflit ou sur la manière de superviser
l'emploi de l'argent des contribuables
américains pour Kief qui reconnaît
l'échec de sa contreoffensive estivale
l'enjeu est crucial Washington est son
premier fournisseur d'assistance
militaire dans le même temps la Russie
intensifie ses attaques en partie ul au
sud et à l'est de l'Ukraine le temps
presse alors que l'hiver va encore
durcir la guerre et la tension
occidentale porté sur la guerre au
Proche Orient fait craindre à Kiev un
affaiblissement de l'aide
internationale et on attend